this particular problem which are
actually easy problem they're given a
bunch of linear equations all over GF 2
I should I mention this all all
operations are happening in there doing
mod 2 operations a bunch of n linear
equations and you're asking of their
simultaneously satisfiable there's an
easy problem of course but what we'll
show is we'll show that there is an X
exponentially longer proof which can be
verified with a verifier which this
takes an amount of time rather than MN
time is the usual verifier would have
taken and we said with the classical NP
witness would have been x gives the
feasible assignment instead of that we
are going to be giving the Audemars
encoding of x what do i mean by that are
the other my encoding of X does this
object is I'm going to take an N bit
string and you're blowing going to blow
it up to two n bits to exponentially
long and what is this exponentially long
every bit every bit of this output we
are going to index it itself by a string
of length n so it's sort of taking X and
you're going to give the dot product of
X with every possible Y so in some sense
it's the truth table evaluation of this
function L of X going from 0 1 n to 0 1
in which Y is mapped to the dot product
with X Y the azimuth encoding is the
truth table of this particular function
and this is what we are going to be
expect as proof
for this see they some X satisfies it we
are going to expect the honors prove it
to provide this as the other mod the
encoding effects and we'll show that we
can check this very locally to check if
X we're a valid witness to it it can be
you can check it and be a convinced with
probability 1 that it is there X
satisfies all these e well if there is
no such X that satisfies all of them no
matter what you give whether you give
the Adama the encoding of some purported
string X or just some other two and bit
long string if the verifier will catch
it with constant probability it will
observe that this is not just let's see
a couple of properties of the other
modern coding so are some other encoding
is you're mapping X sort of code table
of this function y L of X now the baby
are defined L of X L of X is this
function
that's in which the one bit which that's
a white product of XY this is just
shorthand for
[Applause]
because it's a linear function it has
one observation it has this following
property that for all Y Z in 0 1 to the
n L X of Y L X of Z is equal to LX of y
plus Z it has this this property this is
an immediate consequence of this
property is the following suppose the
following self-correction property all
you given some function f
and you know that it is close and f is
Delta close LX for some X what I mean by
that is that is probability over Y of Y
not equal to LX of y this is a function
which on most places it is actually
equal to it but it's possible but you do
not know that if possibly is not equal
to F el éxito a few places saying you do
not know which places these places could
have been chosen address a really and
Delta is some number say less strictly
less than 1/4 then you can actually
recover then for all Z in 0 1 to the N
you can actually
also candidate this one you can just
look at the function f of X plus Z sorry
F of y plus Z minus F of Y
every point that you want to you're
given you're given a sort of corrupted
version of LFX you're not given LFX but
you sort of smudged Delta fraction of it
but yet you can sort of recover the
exact value by sort of this local
correction because you know this is a
random point you just choose F of Y plus
it is a completely random point this is
a random point so these two points are
going to be close to going to be the
right value with probability one minus
Delta each so this in fact this is with
probability one minus two Delta you have
that you actually have recovered this so
even though you have don't have access
to the to the actual linear function you
have access only to some corrupted
version of the linear function it says
with just two queries you can actually
recover the real the actual linear
function from this corrupted value as
long as the corruptions are not too
large so this is one important property
that we will use that they this encoding
has this feature it has the self
correction the other important feature
which will use this sort of disp this is
actually a characterization of LX so if
a function satisfies this let me
[Applause]
F is f is Alex for some X if and only if
for all Y Zed we have the property that
F of Y plus F of Z equals y plus Z this
is sort of a characterization of all the
linear functions it's not just a
characterization it's actually what we
will see what I'll write just know it's
a robust characterization what do I mean
by that you can consider the following
sort of somebody gives you this truth
table F and they claim it's a linear
function and you want to check it's a
linear function or not if it's a linear
function we know it has to satisfy this
property so what one could do is
actually pick a random Y Z and check if
this property is satisfied what we can
show is if the function is far from
linear this test will actually be
violated most of the time if it is
linear of course it's going to be
satisfied all the time that's what this
does saying is the other thing is if the
function is far from linear this test
it's just the three query tests it's an
exponentially long table if this
function is far from being linear just
looking at three queries in it will tell
you whether the function satis is close
to being a linear function or not this
test which was proposed by long Looby
and Rubenfeld following
it gets us input this function not it
doesn't get to read the entire function
it has it's only going to probe it at a
few locations it wants the check is f F
this linear or not
it picks random Y Z 0 1 n robes
esvet y z and y plus z and accepts if f
of y plus Z equals F of Y certainly we
know that this test has the following
just the following practice it has the
following completeness property that is
if s is linear the probability that the
BLR test accepts is 1
non-trivial statement to proof which
request this is due to be a lot Romans
is the following fact all Delta less
than half if the test accepts the
probability greater than 1 minus Delta
then in fact there is some linear
function X such that this Delta close
Alex say this in that sense it's a
robust characterization you can just
probe this function at three locations
and be convinced that it is actually
it's not a it might not be linear but it
is a close to some being linear function
if it is far from linear most of these
tests are going to catch it so if it's
Delta for at least Delta fraction of the
tests will of these tests will sort of
violated Delta fraction of this local
views are going to observe that there is
an inconsistency in the words given then
this truth table is not a linear
function so we'll just use this this is
a non-trivial theorem to prove it going
to assume this this and complete the
proof of our PCP construction
we want to show what the new verifier
the system of linear equations
so it expects us proof some function f
which are the honest case is actually
this LX the X satisfies linear equations
verify steps are going to have two types
of tests one is going to be they're
going to be a few syntactic tests in
which is just going to test if s is of
the right type is it a linear function
and then it's going to check
semantically whether the linear function
it encodes is actually one that
satisfies this one so they're going to
be the tests are going to be of two
types
syntactic tests and semantics the
syntactic tests in this case in fact for
the reason I'm writing it this way even
the subsequent verifies I'm going to
write are all going to have this part
they're going to there's gonna be a
first part of the test which is going to
be syntactic it's going to check if the
encoding have some properties and then
second part is use the encoding czar
encoding of NP witnesses that satisfy
the original predicate they're going to
have this sort of to one and in this
case the syntactic test is clear it's
just going to be run the BL are just
perform BL artist just do this and at
the end of this if this test passes we
know that this function is close to some
linear function it might not be a
lean-to it might it is close to some L X
this area X need not satisfy all the
linear function but we know if this test
passes over here it is going to be close
to some linear function now we need to
check that that X is actually is
actually satisfies all the linear
functions but now and what do we know
once it passes this part of the test we
know that F is close to a linear
function so we actually have access
because if you have a function which is
close to a linear function we can
actually produce the linear function by
doing the self correction so we at this
point once the test passes this we can
do self correction to out obtain the
value of L FX at any point we want to
ideally we would have a like to check
all these places so we could have query
del FX at a one l FX at a to l FX at
a.m. and our answers where we want to be
M we would be done but this is sort of
peaceful in the sense you are doing M
operations anyway here I want to say you
can do something even better so what we
will do is we'll do the following fact
we will
pick em random bits and construct this
vector a which is just the addition of
the M of those of those n vectors it's
going to be some addition of this one
you're going to pick basically for every
AI you're tossing a random coin and
asking whether I'm gonna include it or
not where I'm gonna include it or not
and so on and it when you take the
corresponding action and what we want so
this is an easy fact to it's easy to
check if X satisfies
all all M equations then a of X which is
L X of a is in fact equal to summation
epsilon I VI otherwise probability that
Alex of a equal to epsilon over the
choices of epsilon 1 to epsilon and this
less than or equal to 1/2 this is just a
consequence these are two different
linear functions if they are not the
same linear function they have to be
disagree on at least half the locations
it's much simpler than the Schwartz
Apple lemma but this is just the
consequence of the short simple demo so
we will just use this so we will use
this you would like to query the
function at a but we can't query a a
might be a Corrupter location so we use
self-correction so we'll pick another
completely random one and we will pick
will check f of you look at f of a plus
a prime minus F of a prime is equal to
summation XY
except with us and this is going to this
will check with probability half you
will reject if X did not is the X that
was close to this did not satisfy it you
and rejected otherwise you will pass
this this so this is the this is the N
type proof of it it queries the test
only at X if you notice it exactly five
locations five locations you query it at
five locations
it's an exponentially long proof that's
a caveat of this but getting it at five
locations and the verifier extremely
efficient it's able to check that the
this encoding is actually close this
encoding proves that these things are
simultaneously satisfiable sorry
probably dumb question but I'm still
stuck on the self correction looks like
you're taking something that's good
probability one minus Delta and you're
turning it into something is good with
probability one no no no no it is good
with probability one minus Delta at a
random point this is for every point I'm
going to get so you know at a random
point f of Y is equal to L F X Y but I
want it to be correct at a point of my
choice so it need not be so so they're
saying for my point I'll use two points
both of which are random and be able to
recover it so it's going from average
case to worse kiss and the factors you
can do it with the other math encoding
has powerful enough to do that you do it
in two they're just two queries just
doing the Union bound over here that's
that's why it's a to Delta they are not
independent but this is just Union bound
so it's good question so this is the Phi
query true for this one you're using the
full you using the power of polynomials
rather than just degree one polynomials
and the fact that they have this amazing
local testability property over here
so the test was the test was trying to
check these linear equations the
right-hand side of the linear equations
yeah so it's just checking the random
zero once it's just a random linear
combination of yeah so that does it for
this system which was an easy problem
now you can ask us how do we modify this
when these were not linear equations but
quadratic equations one tough time I'm
not going to go into the details as
quickly tell so the way the Kodama
encoding is viewed so the way we have
viewed it is over here
the Hazama the encoding has two possible
interpretations the interpretation over
here which we are use this it is the
evaluation of a linear function
LX at all points y 0 1 to the end but
because of the symmetry of X&Y this can
also be viewed as is the evaluation of
all linear functions and y at the point
X because of the symmetry of the way x
and y are this one it has this
interpretation so to handle quadratic
things instead of working with so we
will give the encoding of X this will
give valuation of all quadratic
functions at the point X and that has a
similar such test which is actually just
taking the BLR test and sort of souping
up it up with the free worlds algorithm
which justin had mentioned in the
morning you'll use that and that will
give you a quadratic test podriatic and
then you do exactly the same thing over
there I want of time I'm gonna skip and
it has no extra this I'd 1 the main
thing or this fact the heart of the
proof is the fact of both these tests is
the fact that mean the atom all encoding
is linearly testable you can test how
the body encoding the fact that
something is close to other money
encoding by just looking at three bits
that's the main thing is this fact the
soundness of this test this is the
non-trivial state mean and given this we
are able to construct this Phi query
test for so that's the conclusion of the
first part of what I wanted to show this
will show that NP if u is contained in
PCP one son probability over here say
nine ten Oh in this case it was order n
but when you go to quadratic it will be
order n square the number of random bits
basically these are the random the
random bits are n over here and another
n here and this Phi in the quadratic
case I think becomes on 12 or something
these questions on this so you even this
of course this is the issue were here is
that the proof is exponentially long
it's in the case of linear thing it's 2
power n long in the case of quadratic
it'll be 2 power N squared long but the
amazing fact is you could just look at
some constant location a number of
locations to our locations and be
convinced that there is an X that
satisfies all the this is saying and
since there if there is no X a good
fraction it is 1/10 of the location 1/10
of the local views are going to observe
the inconsistency so here sort of
smearing the inconsistency all over the
proof its Sara same thing that's
happening to polynomials if two
polynomials are distinct they're
distinct almost everywhere here if the
proof is false there is no if the
theorem where if there is no X that
satisfies all the equations there is no
way you could come up with one single
proof which hattis Phi's most of the
things you're going to have errors all
over the place it's sort of throwing out
this throwing with the Harris and the
heart of the proof is the testability of
the other mod encoding with the Blom
Looby Rubenfeld test any questions so
far we will now see how to modify this
to reduce the randomness or to make the
proofs shorter the truth is
exponentially long we would want to make
it all in harmony long it's you have to
do a careful analysis of BLR and this
one it will be some constant bounded
away from one yeah
given that I'm not worrying about this
constant you can moose that with this
you can get any constant you want to
what we would now want to do this is we
want to sort of soup the system up to
get it to make the proofs
shorter for the sake of presentation I'm
going to work with a different
np-complete problem C's you could work
with any np-complete problem which has
can be art mattias nicely but we will
change the NP f-- here like a just like
work with system of quadratic equations
I'll work with graph coloring and that
will be most convenient but this is it's
not a feature of the a you could we
should work with any problem over here
so the next part which I'm going to show
is polynomial size PC piece that will be
great with respect to size however we
will get only poly logarithmic query
complexity this is this is also quite
anything it's not it's not what I had
promised constant but this is also
something away looking at the proof at a
very few locations and you still
convinced poly logarithmic
problem may be working with this
tinkling given a graph of it just being
given as V cross V they say which pairs
of vertices or edges assume it's a
symmetric function question asked us
does there exist a coloring
every edge
ask and we will show so the class once
again that the classical NP witness for
this is the 3-coloring itself is the
recoloring if it if one exists
and not sure is what is going to be the
PCP again it's going to be some encoding
coloring which is also going to take the
graph into account which can be very
locally checked in that's good the
encoding is going to be only
polynomially long unlike before it's
going to be Paul nominee long but which
you can check with just looking at the
proof at just poly logarithmic number of
locations that's what we will what is
going to be motivated by this example so
what did we have here we had this
function which was what was this was the
Adama the encoding was low the heart of
the proof was the fact that the Adama
the encoding is locally testable that is
you could check if some function is
close to being the linear function or
not by just looking at it at a few
locations this was crucial in getting
down in ensuring that the encoding had a
syn nice syntactic property and once it
was syntactic the semantic property
could be so we want a similar such thing
we want some man coding in which we can
you can check that the fact it's an
encoding it's a valid encoding very
quickly and then we will somehow use
some map the semantics into the problem
to check this other part so they what we
want is a corresponding this one here
this was checking that checking whether
given linear function is of given
function as linear or not is locally
testable natural generalization is not
going to talk about linear functions but
low degree functions I'm going to talk
about some low function and we have a
table which is supposedly an evaluation
of a low degree function can be check if
it is low degree or not and we'll see if
that actually they show that that is
actually going to work so we're going to
talk about
some degree parameter D
significantly smaller than Q is large
enough so that we can apply Schwartz
Apple and M variate you write it as a
polynomial in other words P can be
written as very unique all the monomials
have degree at less than or equal to D
we look at these functions class of
functions previously we're looking at
the money coding which is class of all
linear functions we look at class of all
this one these are what are going to be
called this cuz this is a reed-muller
code
agree listen these the total degree this
is the total degree yeah and as before
we are going to use the fact that if you
are given two different reed-muller
codes P and Q are two different
reed-muller codes if you pick a random
point if they are the same reed-muller
code of course they will be equal
everywhere if you pick it if they are if
they are distinctly reed-muller code
distinctly low degree polynomials then
almost at every point they will be the
probability that they will be the same
as very small this is why we need the
field size to be considerably larger
than D we choose such a setting of
parameters the reed-muller has this
feature it has this thing once again
that two things are very distinct from
each other but we want to ask if it also
has a similar local testability feature
is the BL are the the linear set of
linear functions had this nice property
it had a very local characterization
that it's F was linear if and only if
this three query tests passed and in and
furthermore if this three query test
passes most of the time and s is
actually close to being linear we want a
similar such property for question s is
there a local test for reed-muller codes
that's actually picture so what do we
have here we are given some function f
on the space so think of this
this is f to the M you're given some
function a truth table or some function
so for every point because you are given
a bad evaluation of F and I want to
check is f actually low degree or not a
very natural test one that suggests if f
is for this setting of parameters D is
larger if F is this parameter you just
pick a random line in this random a fine
line in this space and just look at the
restriction of F to this line that will
be a new also a low degree form function
a univariate low degree function you can
say that F is in reed-muller qmd this is
for certain setting of parameters this
is mdq the following is true this is in
fact a complete characterization that is
f restricted to L is our mq-1b the one
variate version of it for all you are
able to check that this truth table
you're giving a truth table on F to the
M values by just looking at this is Q to
the M values by just looking at Q values
this is sort of a characterization of it
the question is is this also robust
characterization just as this was a
robust characterization for checking if
something is linear this test passes
most of the time and then we knew that
this is close to being linear to you'd
like to know if this test passes most of
the time is this being close to
reed-muller code and in fact that is
true this this is the low degree test
impudence pick a random fine line
yes
except as restricted to L is a
univariate polynomial degree
so certainly it has the completeness
properties yes they're a low degree
function then it's going to pass the
test with probability 1
the amazing thing which is certainly no
completely non-trivial to show is if
they actually the test passes with
probability 1 minus Delta then F is
actually order Delta close to being low
degree
songs of
actual number oh sorry
order dead and Israeli dependence on the
DVD so this Delta naught is going to be
it's it's Delta naught is some function
of the form M power a deeper V over C
for ABC being universal constants
therefore we will just choose them
we'll choose em D and Q such that that
is at fixed constant and you will have
to choose a large enough field so that
this is small and
this is just you do interpolation it's
just so it but it's the interpolation
and much smaller it's not the whole
space it's a smaller space notice that
this is sublinear
even when when M is 2 or so also you are
checking and there are something like n
square points we're just looking at n
points you're able to check if it's a
you're able to check something by
querying it at a very few locations much
smaller than the whole length which is a
spirit of course PCP is you want to
check the proof is valid by looking at
them much fewer locations than the
entire proof so this is going to be sort
of the technical core just like we're
going to replace the the syntactic test
we're going to give just like over
previously we had given the proof was
the Hazama the encoding of X the proof
isn't now the new proof is going to be
something else it's going to be some
reed-muller encodings of some functions
related to the coloring and the
syntactic test is just basically going
to check that all these functions are
actually low-degree functions we will
just do this low degree function for all
of them and then we will do some set of
semantic tests to check that those low
degree functions the F the low degree
functions which are close to the proofs
actually are encoding of things which
are valid 3 colorings no no no this
formula is wrong over here eyes this one
let me I think there might be a 1 -
going on over there so let me it is
I wrote it itself I realized as they're
hoping somebody would catch me the
univariate case so anyway you just have
Q points you want to check something if
Q points is variable you take the first
D points or D plus 1 points interpolate
to get the polynomial and check the
remaining Q minus D plus 1 points I have
same one
that's one easy way of doing that you
could do any other so you query F on all
the points along the line here say f is
given as a truth table and you want to
check that this F is actually so for
every point in F to the M you are given
the value of F and you want to check
that this truth you want to look at this
truth table but not read it come in
priority and be convinced that it is
actually close to being low degree so we
will probe it only at locations along
the line here pick a random line yell in
the space and probe it along so so for a
certain setting of so we will set m to
be such that the relation between Q and
s to the M will be log n will be poly
log n so that we are depending on how
much time I have I'll do this parameter
setting eventually the poly log in the
query complexity over here is going to
come from the fact that a line is going
to be poly logarithmically smaller than
the entire space it's going to be there
go me several reed-muller codes that are
going to be so it will be several some
constant times yes is going to be four
this is yes yes yes yeah but if I am so
it's not in the bit complexity world its
F in which each query itself is a field
element impressions
so what do we want to check we want to
check there exist coloring see on the
vertices which is a proper three
coloring working with polynomials I'm
going to state this proper three
coloring this fact in a polynomial
fashion so we notice we had this edges
edges with a function V cross V 2 0 1
which it's one of the edges there and 0
otherwise so this is equivalent to
stating this statement is equivalent to
stating the edge I J so you want a I
minus AJ
sorry CI minus CJ should never be 0 it
should be 1 off it should be 1 2 minus 1
minus 2 so you're just going to check
this fact minus 1
I should be zero for all IJ v cross
either the edge is absent or the edge is
present then the at least the color
should be distinct this sort of captures
the fact it's of three coloring so we
want a sea which has this property
furthermore so sea should also be
because we eventually we're going to be
sort of taking low degree extensions of
the sea is going to be a function from
v2 zero one two we're going to push P 2
F so you also want to say C is actually
a is a three coloring this will be one
condition condition one other condition
we'll check is actually C has the
property that in for every vertex it
gives one of these two
there is a C that satisfies both these
properties we're a dog so what we will
do is we will not instead of giving C we
are going to give some polynomials
related to C in particular we are going
to give the sort of the low degree
extension of C in a particular cleverly
chosen fashion which will help us to
check these two properties extremely
fast this is where the earth Mehta's
ation is going to come so now we're
going to our my ties the problem so far
it has all been on the original space
we have the space f to the M so we
somehow have to move from the vertex
space the function the domain of the
functions are V we want to move the
domain being s to the M where we will
sort of do this we pick some s which is
a subset of F look at the smaller sub q
of s to the M we're going to look this
this smaller cube of F to the M with the
property that we will identify SM now in
some canonical fashion with the set of
vertices so V is going to s to the M is
going to be is just the alternate
labeling of the vertices this is going
to be the same size as what is this some
canonical fashion we're going to do this
so now we can view the functions C as a
function from F to the M to F and G as a
function from s m cross s M
you have given once we do this
identification we can view them this way
and now we will do what that was a low
degree extension that Justin was talking
we will extend these functions right now
these functions are defined only on this
sub Q we will sort of extend it to the
whole space so we will talk of this is
the sort of the low degree extension
we are going to talk about a capital C
going from s to the M to s going from F
to the 2m f was that she had been
restricted to hm SM is identical to C
and we had restricted to s to M is
identical today we're going to think of
some extension of this function but
maintaining loda greenness so this is
this can always be done such that the
degree of C hat and the degree of we had
this utmost modest in each variable
this is always this is not hard to check
it's it's doable the univariate case so
if you have a function if you are given
a function only on yes locations and you
want to extend it to f locations there
exist a degree s function sort of
stating the same thing for the
multivariate worship so this will take
we're going to ask us proofs C hat and
he had he had this sum he had is
something a verifier has the verifier
can compute it itself c hat the verifier
does not have the v ec hat is what the
verifier is going to expect as proof so
the proof is going to be they're going
to be several parts of the proof
certainly one is going to be this
function C hat from F to the M yes we
can check it's low degree but we will
have to give some more additional
information to check that C hat
satisfies these two properties people
with me so you want to show that C have
C is a valid 3 coloring so instead of
giving C we are going to give the low
degree extension of C just like over
there we gather Haddam are the encoding
and then we need to give some additional
information to show that C hat satisfies
these properties
what's additional information I'm going
to give so I want to check that this is
true so I'm going to give another
function let's call this C 1 is C 1 and
C 1 in the honest case should be equal
to C hat
and c2 is going to be just is also is
going to be the function which is just x
CX minus 1 is minus 2 it's going to be
this low degree function so I'm going to
ask expect us proof even the second
function going from F to the M we're
going to give this and what we need to
now check we need to check to restrict
it to SM is identically 0 not c2 but the
polynomial that c2 is close to is
identically 0 on s to the M and the
relation between c1 and c2 but that
actually is an easy thing to do if feels
yeah I'll come to that this is just a
polynomial identity so if you check it
at a random point if they are true
they're true everywhere so we will
expect as a one table for c1 another
table for c2 and then we're going to
check that please and now we're going to
do the same thing we're going to check
we're going to ask as another another
table B which is just going to be a hat
of IJ a hat of X Y and this complicated
expression which I have CX minus CY
minus 1 this function will ask this
function this is also going to be we're
going to ask be going from F to m2 f
[Music]
this and we also now we need to check be
on s2m
this point what are you doing that's
is going to perform as before low degree
test on c1 c2 to be convinced that they
are odd even if they are not low degree
they are close to being low degree it's
going to do some bunch of semantic tests
tests will come of two types one is you
have to check what amethyst will have to
check that c2 has been derived properly
from c1 B has been derived properly from
v2 but these are all polynomial
identities so it's sufficient to check
them at a random point so we'll just
just checking they were different they
would because at this point if this test
has passed you're convinced that they
are close to a random they are close to
a low degree function therefore if they
were low degree then a random location
they have to be if they pass the
identity they had to satisfy the
identity at every location and if they
are not satisfied an identity that is
satisfied violate the identity at most
locations so this is fine we need to
still do these two tests that's the last
semantic property just we didn't check
the low degree function degree
polynomial close to c2 and also be just
identically zero on SM and similarly
that's one last thing do and if you're
done with that we will pass the so how
do we check this we are now going to the
final property we need to check you're
given some funk you're given a low
degree polynomial and you want to check
its identically 0 on a sub cube well
natural things take a random point and
check 0 but this is actually this one
because you have to check it a zero
everywhere it might be true that it is
zero everywhere except one location and
that's enough to violate it being an
entre color we need to check that it is
zero completely in the specified we need
to do it by looking at but not by
querying this entire table but by
quitting very small number of locations
how this one do this this is sort of
inspired by the some check but is going
to be much simpler than the some check
protocol let's ask the univariate
version of this problem
yeah what so what let's let me turn what
all has happened so far so what all has
happened so we need to check that there
is a we need to go check that there is a
coloring which is a valid three coloring
and we saw that something is a valid
three coloring event at charter we need
to check that exist see that satisfies
two properties one is it is actually
gives for every vertex it gives only one
of these three coloring that CI into CI
minus one due to CI minus two is zero
and the other is this test which I had
just arrest yeah I J that is for every
edge the two colors provided our
distinct colors we need to check this so
what we instead do is going to we are
not going to put so we see is not going
to provide it in its natural format but
in the in the know degree and coding of
it in stuff we identify the vertex set
with some sub cube of this large space
so this is f to the m identifying way to
some sub cube and instead of providing C
and just the sub cube we are going to
provide the low degree function that is
an extension of the sub cube okay we
expect the prover to provide this view
the prover could cheat and provide
something else so C 1 the first part of
the proofs in the honest case should be
the low degree extension of C and now we
need to check that this load it's a low
degree extension of some coloring that
satisfies these two properties so for
that you also give that corresponding
low degree extensions of those two
polynomials so C 2 is the polynomial
which is just caught as CFX C of X minus
1 C of X minus 2 we asked the prover to
provide that function also and also the
function the low degree function
corresponding to this so the prover is
going to provide all these three low
degrees
the truth table so it's say each of them
the eventual parameters will be
everything will be poor right now
everything's going to be for linear an F
to the M and we will be setting the
field size and M such that this is
Pauline n eventually so I don't know if
I'll come to that so eventually will be
Q M will be said to be equal to poly N
and Q will be something like poly log
and M will be log n by log log n this
will set satisfy those parameters so the
prover is going to provide these three
tables now we need to check that these
three tables are correct
that is you can check that a low degree
in SPL using the low degree test we've
checked it we need to check C 2 has been
obtained correctly from C 1 just check
it at a random point these are low now
the idea convinced they are low degree
functions checking at a random point
you're guaranteed that C 2 is in fact
precisely this low degree function which
will be taxable this would be hats
what if he is what if you have to check
the edge is corresponds to the graph I
have no but he is something the verifier
can compute it said so this part of it
it's going to compute this one and these
three it's going to pull out so it's
going to check this location he is
something the he had is something the
verifier can compute of its own and C
hat it's going to read from the other
table and check so it's going to check
the B is being given correctly by
checking this polynomial identity so at
this point we are come to a place where
we know that the tables that we have are
in fact low degree polynomials and they
have been obtained correctly from each
other what we do not know is that they
are low degree extensions of functions
that satisfies these two identities so
we need to check that see to the flow
degree polynomial close to c2 is
identical on s to the M and similarly
for B less less this one one of them
let's look at the univariate version of
this and you say there's an immediate
zero everywhere because certainly c2 is
not zero everywhere it is it could be
zero every it's good throw happen c1 it
mean the only low degree extension of
this possible is being zero everywhere
but we need to check that and notice the
natural test of just picking a random
you have these polynomials checking them
at a random point here checking if it is
zero is not it's not good because this
could be just that it could be not be
zero at one place and this is impossible
to do it by random query
extension query the entire thing you're
basically querying all the vortex which
is the same thing of the original NP
witness you want to do something much
better if it was zero everywhere then
you could have done but we don't know if
it is zero everywhere yeah observation
and the univariate setting is the
following thing suppose P is a function
from F to F of degree less than or equal
to D and P happens to be identically 0
on s what can you say about P
then this must be true that tea is in
fact as a polynomial equivalent to the
polynomial that bra we can say that if
you look at this polynomial zs which is
a polynomial that vanishes on s not use
Q the SS then there exists a polynomial
P prime of a - size of s such that this
half P is equal to Z s times P Prime the
only way this can happen in the
univariate setting is if Z s is a factor
of P so to prove that p is identically 0
on s what I could give proof P Prime and
then check this polynomial identity so
you could give us proof - this is a
proofs P is identically 0 on s this
actually P prime of degree a - sizes and
then check the polynomial identity
P equals ßièsq P Prime at a random
location do that then this is true in
the univariate setting how do we do it
in the multivariate setting this natural
extension for this right
[Applause]
identically 0 on the sub-q if and only
if there exists polynomials 1t they are
actually even smaller degree but this is
good enough for me so that P is
identically the polynomial GH X I
yes yes
this is just the multivariate extension
of the same statement there I said that
P is equal to the product of Z s and P
Prime here P will be equal to some
foundation of this form it's clear if
it's of this form then P is identically
equal to 0 the other part is also not
hard to prove it just do repeated
division M times and maybe they divide P
by Z X x1 the 2 by P and then the
remainder polynomial has to be
identically 0 it's just this so this so
to show that P is identically 0 and SM
the proof is going to be polynomials D 1
D 2 D M so we're going to give these as
extra proofs the proof is for this one
it's going to have a set of polynomials
d 1 d 2 d m and this one is going to
have another set of polynomials s 1 F 2
SM syntactical e you check all of these
are low degree polynomials and then the
last one you check that for C 2 so C 2
at a random point X is equal to
summation d hxi into 3 I of X for random
X
so you're convinced that if you give me
all of these proofs tables there are
about order M of them which blows up the
proof by a log n factor so on this whole
long proof actually encodes a satisfying
three coloring a valid three coloring of
the and notice it the only you're
querying the proof only on certain lines
sort of M lines because all that's been
happening order M lines that's the first
complexity and the parameters you will
get that this gives you a poly log you
can check that this actually says three
coloring is in PCP some 199 over hundred
order log in tell you why we have an
order log in poly log in the order log
in comes from you need to pick a random
line or a random point space how much is
it has been set such that QM is poly n
so random point or random line is going
to be picking log in I don't know sent
yeah at this point I think let's not go
into the parameters just setting this
actually for any setting of M is
actually going to give you a non-trivial
PCP theorem it's going to say that you
can query a proof of length some proof
in say in route and locations
insufficient you can if you set m to be
like five or six we will get that you're
wearing a able to query a proof of
length n in just square root n locations
and be convinced of its capacity if you
said these parameters you will go down
all the way to poly log in and yeah
he had model over so he had so in the
case of coloring it has to do he had
that's a expensive thing but for most
problems if the he had the typical earth
motivation has done such that he is if
you you can use the sort of succinct
circuit format in which given a you can
X arithmetic it and get this also
efficiently so the hard part is not Yi
actually in this the hard part is
computing Z H X I it has to also compute
Z H X I that happens to be an intensive
task so we can actually say it happens
to okay for actually this poly log and
setting it might be no this setting it
will be this one is it's fine this is
fine we wanna check those combination of
what
no there you had a linear combination I
don't see how to do a random linear
combination randomly I need to evaluate
the Phong there you interpreted the fact
that given X they had the more the
encoding give every linear function on X
therefore a random linear function was
also a linear function now a random this
one might not be something we don't have
X we don't have the coloring at every
low degree for we don't have every low
degree polynomials evaluation at X so
Hatami had this two properties it little
version use some check this is a cleaner
version to it is is the same thing as
some check said in a much more succinct
fashion this is a polynomial identity
just like over here it's a polynomial
identity if P is identically 0 on s this
has to be an identity busiest should be
a factor of this it should hold
therefore this this polynomial right it
is as if this is true for all if you
apply alpha it's true at every alpha the
same thing is true it's a polynomial
identity therefore it's true either it's
true everywhere or it will false at most
look locations with all the things it is
giving so there will be whole bunch of
is everything is going to be added over
there yes
just picture if you didn't seize it is
it Paulo means he is a fixed polynomial
yes yes yes it's a fixed polynomial in
this yeah it could make that also
efficiently actually it's done in some
of the works in which well if you choose
s to be not right now s was an arbitrary
set if you're chosen has to be a
subgroup then Z will have only it will
have very few nonzero coefficients and
they can make that also so extremely
efficient in that that's used in trying
to get the verifies even more efficient
then you don't have to any robust it's
the this llama has nothing to do with
low degree it says you feel given
already a low degree polynomial yeah but
you're checking it at a random location
therefore it's fire you once you know
it's close you can if you're checking it
at a random location its yeah once it
passes this test in the case of Hamas we
had to query it automatic robust version
of also yeah yeah Schwarz Apple is an
automatic robust version once you know
once you pass this you once did all
polynomial identities become robust
because of Schwarz Apple yeah
okay
[Applause]